there were tailbacks on Paris's famous
Shahs Alizee Avenue and across the city
with most of the metro bus and train
services closed people sought
alternative ways to get around the
biggest transport workers strike in the
French capital for more than a decade
cause travel chaos and frustration for
commuters the idea is to be able to
strike or protest using methods which
don't prevent others going to work I'm
avoiding public transport because I
thought it would be busy and delayed
transport workers are protesting against
the French president Emmanuel macron
planned pension reforms the French
government says it wants to streamline
the complex and costly pension system to
make it fairer and financially
sustainable we are going to build a
truly Universal system which for every
euro contributed gives everyone the same
rights whether they are workers
shopkeepers researchers farmers civil
servants doctors or entrepreneurs these
transport workers say they're worried
their pensions could be reduced or they
could be forced to work longer most
people in France can retire at 62 but
some Transport Workers can retire in
their 50s our patient schemes are sacred
we accepted jobs for shift work we're
responsible for public safety but now
they want to take our rights away we are
being asked to take on increasingly
difficult working conditions while
losing what little compensation we had
many people in France regard the state
public pension scheme as a pillar of the
French social system previous French
presidents who've tried to reform it
have backed down after public opposition
reforming france's pension system was
one of Emmanuel macron campaign promises
but it's fraught with risk opinion polls
suggest that the French president's
popularity is finally on the rise after
a difficult year domestically because of
the yellow fest protests so he'll have
to tread carefully if he wants to avoid
a new wave of street demonstrations most
French people probably accept that the
system needs changing it's no longer
financially viable for the coming decade
so it's a calculated risk but Emmanuel
macron has gained in popularity since
his good results in European
elections and his great national debate
so he has momentum the government says
it will draw up proposed pension reforms
after lengthy consultations with trade
union leaders and the public a strategy
the president may be gambling on to give
him the green light to continue with
this sweeping reform agenda but it won't
be easy workers from other sectors are
planning similar strikes in the coming
weeks
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Paris